this is my father Sasha a lot of you
don't know my dad I love my dad very
very much got some interesting um
comments from the Larry King episode
that I did you know that I go you really
give your dad some good apps and you
know it's funny my kids are getting
older and becoming a more experienced
dad and I think that you know you know
obviously we got to know each other in
the late 90s and early 2000s because you
just worked so hard and I thank you for
that dad I thank you so much for
sacrificing and I know you did it in a
selfish way because I do it too in a
selfish way I know that it's your
natural state to be an entrepreneur and
build for yourself but it doesn't take
away from the fact of what you did and
what you established and how you started
the process of our family being here not
only did you but you brought the whole
family along with you including your mom
and your grandparents and you came to
this country and you worked so damn hard
and and you know it's funny I think
through all our frictions in building
the business it's super easy and has
always been super easy for me to focus
on how we're different and what I don't
agree on but I've been noticing a trend
especially maybe because I don't see you
every day like I used to and I'm not
around as much on an everyday basis with
you but it's been interesting to me over
the last 24 months 36 months to start
being more in tune than ever with not
our differences but our similarities
back in the day in the late 90s early
2000s I really thought that I was 90%
mom and 10% you and that's really just
because I didn't know you as well dad
it's funny to me to recognize how much
more similar I am to you than I realized
and you know and I just want you to know
how much you mean to me and and even
though I think for a long time in my 20s
and 30s that my own ego and my own pride
was so scared for the narrative to be
that you're the reason I was successful
that you're you know even to this day
dad
I know you don't read the comments
the Internet you'd find it interesting
how many people in a youtube comment
will say well don't listen to this guy
his he is dad you know had a liquor
store and that's why he's successful I'm
so scared of that dad I'm so scared of
that in my teens in my 20s it was the
biggest fear I had and now as those
negative comments or or people that push
back are the far minority I find myself
being passionate to make sure that your
legacy isn't lost and what you did isn't
left behind and it doesn't become the
narrative of just what I've accomplished
without the context of what you
accomplished and how much you helped me
to get there and so once you know that
then I want you to know it now not when
you're 90 or 100 or 130 when you're on
your deathbed but I want you to know it
now of how much you mean to me and how
thankful I am and how much I learned
from the way that you and mom navigated
and how I do think my hard work and my
hustle is my separation from the
marketplace and I know that's a learned
behavior by watching how you did it and
I thank you from the bottom my heart and
so I thought it was a good time to say
hey I love you
thanks for being on the show then go
husbands of may we're changing the one
who's more dogmatic my song bored me
Jesus they're gonna love you for this
episode you're gonna get more votes than
you deserve